ce sens public continue avec ses images
de centaines de civils tués à bout de
chats près de kiev ces images et ces
mots qui reviennent dans tous les débats
en france et dans la plupart des pays
occidentaux crimes de guerre comment
trouver que des crimes de guerre ont été
commis par l'armée russe première
réponse avec flora sauvage il faudra des
semaines peut-être des mois d' enquête
pour comprendre ce qui s'est passé à
bout de chat à 30 km aux environs de
kiev après le départ des troupes russes
c'est la consternation devant les fosses
communes et les corps laissé à l'abandon
dans les rues de la ville on ne sait pas
précisément combien il y a deux victimes
on pense qu'il y en aurait plus de trois
cents 300 civils qui sont morts ici
arrivé sur place le président ukrainien
dénonce un génocide
la communauté internationale exprime
elle son indignation alors que l'union
européenne réfléchit à de nouvelles
sanctions contre moscou emmanuel macron
condamne avec la plus grande fermeté ce
massacre il est clair qu'il ya des
indices aujourd'hui très claire de
crimes de guerre c'est l'armée russe qui
était à bout de champ si la russie nie
être à l'origine du massacre à mouthe
chat et dénoncent une mise en scène de
la part des ukrainiens le chef de la
diplomatie américaine assure que tout
sera fait pour apporter des preuves à la
cour pénale internationale
depuis l'invasion de l'ukraine par la
russie nous n'avons pas arrêté de dire
que nous pensons que les troupes russes
commettent des crimes de guerre nous
travaillons désormais pour apporter les
preuves de ces crimes aux institutions
concernées car ils doivent être tenus
pour responsables
de son côté l'union européenne s'est
déclarée prête à envoyer des équipes
d'enquêteurs en ukraine pour aider au
recueil de preuves sur les crimes de
guerre et les crimes contre l'humanité
dont les forces russes seraient
responsables
comment on pouvait comment juger des
crimes de guerre c'est le thème de notre
débat et j'accueille jeunes super bon
soir en sari avenue vous êtes avocate
responsable de la commission justice
internationale
amnesty international france galia
ackerman bonsoir historienne spécialiste
de la russie post-soviétique frappé le
titre de votre livre le régiment
immortel la guerre sacrée de poutine on
est aux éditions premier parallèle
christian makarian bonsoir soit
bienvenue à vous aussi journaliste au
point et à radio notre-dame et matthieu
croissandeau évidemment il rester à mes
côtés je ne suggère vous avez chez
amnesty un laboratoire de preuves
l'évidence lab ce qu'il s'est passé à
bout de schaaf est il déjà l'objet d'un
travail de pour recueillir des preuves s
qui a déjà peut-être sur le terrain ou
alors en récupérant des images
satellites et s il ya déjà un travail
qui a commencé très certainement
le evidence lab en fait c'est un
mécanisme qui permet dans les situations
telles que qu'actuellement lorsque les
chercheurs ne peuvent pas se rendre dans
les territoires en conflit pour des
questions de sécurité de faire des
recoupements à travers des sources
ouvertes de corroborer à travers un
certain nombre de choses des images
satellites des expertises ondes en
termes d'armement
de
permettre en fait une documentation là
où il est impossible d'aller donc pour
le moment on n'a pas à amnesty n'a pas
encore sorti deux rapports sur les
derniers faits mais je pense que ça ne
serait tarder alors on le sait ces
éléments de preuve enfin ces
informations proviennent à la fois de
citoyens mais aussi d'image satellite
mais aussi de défenseurs des droits
humains qui sont soit sur le terrain
soit aux frontières donc toute une série
de tout où tu sais vous dire que là ce
n'est pas possible d'avoir des des
enquêteurs d'amnesty international sur
le terrain c'est trop dangereux ils n'y
sont pas où certains ils sont quand même
ça dépend où au fur et à mesure
peut-être que l'armée ukrainienne
reprend des territoires se serait
peut-être possible pour eux d'y aller on
peut l'imaginer on peut tout à fait
imaginer bon il ya des chercheurs qui
vont aussi près que possible sur le
terrain et pour des questions de
sécurité il ya certains endroits qui
sont inaccessibles
enquêter en temps réel c'est c'est
extrêmement difficile
la question lassé de documenter
d'essayer de préserver les preuves de
faire en sorte qu'ils aient pas de
destruction preuve on et amnesty comme
les autres face à de réelles difficultés
et on sait ça reste une organisation de
la société civile sans moyens autres que
ceux d'une organisation de la société
civile donc on fait avec les moyens
possibles mais les vitesses lab c'est un
moyen aussi de plus en plus
avec une modeuse une méthodologie très
rigoureuse qui permet quand même
d'avancer que certains crimes ont été
commis et surtout aussi de démêler le
faux le vrai du faux alors justement
cela qui est intéressant galia ackerman
c'est là la réponse de moscou depuis
depuis 24-48 heures qui rejette
catégoriquement les accusations de deux
de crimes de guerre c'est pas une
surprise et ce sera certainement la
ligne de défense de vladimir poutine et
de ses généraux pendant les prochaines
semaines et les prochains mois et
peut-être plus vous savez ils ont déjà
fait à plusieurs reprises à chaque fois
qui est un crime commis par l'armée
russe au des militaires pro russes ou
des mercenaires wagner
la russie projette d'autres
responsabilités c'était pareil en syrie
quand il ya eu une attaque chimique
cinq mille personnes ont trouvé la mort
et la russie parlez d'une mise en scène
faite par les casques blancs à
l'organisation
des droits de l'homme basé je crois en
grande bretagne et qui étaient sur place
quand il y avait l'avion abattu au
dessus du ciel de donetsk que de 198
passagers qui sont morts il ya des
preuves indiscutables que c'était un
lance-missile transportait du territoire
russe sur le territoire sous contrôle
des rebelles
le donc ça l'avion a été abattu et
ensuite se lance missile a été rapatrié
en russie les russes ont émis au moins
dix hypothèses différentes pour
complètement embrouiller le scénario la
stratégie est déjà en syrie il parlait
d'une mise en scène là maintenant il ose
dire que certains cadavres qu'on voit
les corps dans les rues que en fait
c'est des acteurs qui sont vivants et
qui
donc on peut voir sur certaines vidéos
que en fait cesser ces corps bouge
la russie
s'adresse au conseil de sécurité pour
accuser les nazis ukrainien donc de
secret envoyé on est dans dans un niveau
de denis absolument incroyable christian
ma carrière dans un conflit comme celui
là il ya plusieurs il ya des moment de
bascule comme est ce que c'est un moment
de bascule d'après vous on a vécu avec
la révélation c'est la découverte de ces
de ces images de ces centaines de civils
tués à abuja c'est un moment de bascule
parce que il intervient et il faut pas
le délié de la stratégie russe il
intervient au moment où les russes
avaient dit et publiquement fait savoir
qu'ils se retiraient de la zone et de
kiev pour se recentrer sur l'est et moi
nous en serons dernières infos haut
responsable du pentagone qui dit que les
deux tiers des forces risque occuper la
région de kiev depuis début de
l'invasion se sont repliés vers le
bélarus voilà or si on regarde les
atrocités commises dans l'état de nos
connaissances qui est évidemment encore
très parcellaires mais on ne peut pas
décorer les ces deux événements comme si
les russes avaient voulu transmettre ce
message là haut population ukrainienne
qu'ils ont voulu et terrorisés voilà
vous pensez qu'on se retire mais voilà
ce qu'on laisse est ce qu'on la sueur
sur place ce sont des fausses commis des
atrocités et puis une double vitesse
dans ces atrocités
le temps qu'on a pu prendre pour
construire des fosses communes n'a rien
à voir avec ces voitures écrasées par
des chars à la dernière minute où des
gens abattus comme ce cycliste ce pauvre
cycliste qui gisait par terre les mains
attachées dans le dos donc il ya la fois
des choses froidement organisée avec des
ordres du commandement parce qu'un
soldat allemand des initiatives de ce
type là creux alors ça ce sera l'un des
aveux dire qu'il en a reçu les ordres et
donc et une hiérarchie et c'est pas un
sergent ou un sous-officier qui donne de
tels ordres c'est un officier vous dites
c'est de la stratégie ou presque de
communication le mot est horrible quand
on sait de quoi on parle je lui ai dit
voilà le message que l'armée russe
envoie et peut-être à ceux qui sont dans
notre région vers lesquels ils se
replient c'est en tout cas à intégrer la
stratégie russe et ne pas le considérer
comme une bavure détacher de l'ensemble
du reste parce que nous savons que
depuis le début la population a été
ciblée et que les forces russes ont pris
l'option guerre totale c'est-à-dire
effrayer terroriser la population
avec ces risques là et enfin la dernière
leçon ménages très très bref c'est sur
le plan strictement militaire
voilà quand même une armée
particulièrement mal organisés qui
laisse des soldes à commettre ce type
d'exactions totalement désordonnée la
voie centrale
le goût de chaque on voit avec les
voitures écrasées et encore la clé du
contact ça veut dire que là probablement
la voiture roulait quand le chat lui a
roulé dessus ce sont des choses qui
implique évidemment forcément toute la
chaîne de commandement jusqu'au niveau
le plus élevé mais sont des choses qui
traduisent aussi une arme est
littéralement d'aigus ni ce qu'est ce
que vous décrivez parce qu'à la fin vous
nous dit tiens il ya une chaîne de
commandement il ya des ordres et de et
de l'autre c'est un peu oui totalement
désorganisé oui il ya des ordres froid
et creuser des fosses et de l'autre de
l'autre côté il ya un laisser-aller qui
est une citation il ya des ordres et à
l'incitation à cette espèce de tueries
et ça c'est la marque d'une armée dans
laquelle le soldat n'est pas bien traité
du reste les soldats on le sait par le
thème enjeux civile arrêtent des gens
dans les rues pour leur prendre du café
ou du thé parce qu'ils n'en n'ont pas la
condition sans doute du soldat de base
russe est certainement très mauvaise
alors dans ce débat il faut rapidement
définir de quoi l'on parle et je propose
un style jourdain de me rejoindre à
steve les mots évidemment ils ont un
sens ils ont un sens sociaux juridiques
crimes de guerre c'est une violation
très grave du droit international
humanitaire si notion vieille comme la
guerre et pourtant aucun texte ne
définit à lui seul tous les crimes de
guerre il faut fouiller un peu il ya
trois grands textes a en gros qui
définissent aujourd'hui ces crimes il ya
des conventions de l'est les conventions
de genève et l'article 8 le plus récent
l'article 8 du statut de rome de 1998 en
résumé en quelques mots thomas un crime
de guerre c'est une violation des lois
et des coutumes de la guerre alors quels
sont les actes interdits en temps de en
temps de guerre ils sont nombreux on
peut en citer quelques-uns il ya les
homicide intentionnel la torture la
déportation des populations la
destruction de biens non justifiées par
les nécessités militaires on pense aux
écoles on peut s'opposer zones
résidentielles ou encore le pillage tout
ça ce sont donc des crimes de guerre
selon le droit international le droit
international qui interdit aussi
l'emploi de certaines armes il s'agit
par exemple des gaz toxiques ou encore
des bombes à sous munitions on en a
beaucoup parlé récemment ces bombes à
sous munitions elles sont très
imprécises elles font énormément de
dégâts parmi les civils c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça qu'elles ont été interdites en
2010 par la convention d'oslo en or des
bombes à sous-munitions mourey était
utilisé par l'armée russe en ukraine
selon plusieurs témoignages alors
commençons son juge ces éventuelles
crises et la cpi la cour pénale
internationale située à l'oeil qui est
compétente mais avant le jugement il ya
le temps de l'enquète les enquêteurs de
la cpi doivent aller sur le terrain pour
récolter les preuves de ces crimes de
guerre ils prennent des photos des
vidéos il tente de documenter ce qui
s'est vraiment passé sur le terrain il
essaie notamment de déterminer quelles
sont les armes qui ont été utilisés pour
faire ce travail bien les enquêteurs
peuvent s'appuyer notamment sur le
travail d'organisation sur place me
d'associations et même que citoyen et
puis ensuite les juristes entre
enseignes les analyses l'épreuve tentes
et bien d'établir le contexte des faits
de déterminer quels ont été les victimes
qui sont les auteurs de ces crimes
présumés ce sont les procès qui peuvent
être très longs mais qui peuvent
déboucher sur un mandat d'arrêt est sûre
des peines de prison c'est par exemple
ce qui c'est passé dans le cas du
génocide au rwanda merci steve pour ses
explications jeanne suter est ce que
vous diriez qu'amnistie internationale
et un travail aussi en lien avec la cour
pénale dans un cas comme celui-là c'est
à dire que les preuves que vous pouvez
récupérer vont servir aux enquêteurs de
la cour pénale
alors la documentation n'a pas pour
objet de vedettes reversés dans une
procédure pénale d'accord
certaines organisations travaillent dans
ce sens pour un contentieux pour faire
du contentieux stratégique amnesty
documente ce qui se passe en ukraine
mais amnesty documente les violations
des droits humains dans le monde entier
fédéral font des rapports qui constitue
ensuite des sources qui vont être
importantes comme information pour
constituer des débuts de l'anc est donc
un certain nombre de rapports vont
effectivement être envoyées au bureau du
procureur ou vont être pris la
connaissance la connaissance de ces
rapports vin va intéresser le pô le
bureau du procureur mais aussi les
juridictions nationales il n'y a pas que
la cour pénale internationale qui est
qui est compétente pour juger les crimes
de guerre et il ya déjà et en premier
lieu les juridictions ukrainienne qui
travaillent qui enquêtent la procureure
ukrainienne enquête de façon extrêmement
active elle a ouvert une page sur
internet permettant à tout un chacun de
venir contribuer à l'établissement des
faits oui avant goût de sa part nous on
paye à plusieurs faits sur lesquels les
équipes d'amnesty international ont déjà
ou sont en train d'enquêter évidemment
absolument oui oui obtient avec de
potentiels crimes de guerre là aussi
avec de potentiels crimes de guerre
aussi et donc c'est une multiplicité en
fait de documentation investi vient
contribuer dans ces documentation mais
il ya aussi une commission d' enquête
qui a été mise en place par les nations
unies donc il ya un certain nombre de
mécanismes qui tous se complètent se
complète d'une manière ou d'une autre
que ce soit devant les juridictions
nationales les juridictions
internationales encore une fois la cpi
n'est que complémentaires des
juridictions nationales les juridictions
nationales ont aussi un rôle à jouer en
matière de crimes internationaux lorsque
les crimes sont des crimes de guerre des
crimes contre l'humanité ou des crimes
de génocide on considère qu'il est une
responsabilité partagée de la part de la
communauté internationale de connaître
deux points
ces crimes galia ackerman à chaque fois
que vous vous reçoit dans cette émission
vous êtes venu à plusieurs reprises vous
êtes un peu notre vigie de l'opinion
russe puisque vous regarder les chaînes
de télévision
et on se demande toujours ce que les
russes peuvent savoir on peut voir de ce
que nous on voit dans un cas comme celui
là est ce qu'il ya une infime partie des
images de boue de chat qui leur arrive
ou alors est-ce qu'elle leur arrive de
toute façon manipulé par
voilà parle par le pouvoir voyez ce que
je veux dire est ce que il ya une
possibilité que les images telles que
nous on les analyse arrive aux russes à
une petite partie de l'opinion ou pas
le problème c'est pas les arrivages des
images et ya encore quelques jours en
effet et il y avait le discours officiel
comme quoi les troupes russes bombarde
uniquement des infrastructures
militaires et détruisent le potentiel
militaire de l'ukraine il touche pas aux
civils il touche pas aux bâtiments aux
immeubles d'habitation est donc cette
horrible scène de d'une femme enceinte
qu'on sortait du de la maternité de
mario paul les russes ont écrit que
c'était une mise en scène cette femme
est morte à l'hôpital et son bébé est
mort avant elle donc ça veut dire que
l'image peut être diffusé à la
télévision russe mais le commentateur va
dire cette assistance est donc
maintenant comme apparemment il ya trop
d'image pour qu'on puisse tout les
occulter on montre en effet butch a
totalement détruite avec les corps
gisant dans les rues mais on dit que
tout cela est une mise en scène
ukrainienne
ou pour marie paule qui est détruite à
90% on dit que ce sont
les nationalistes les nazairiens qui ont
délibérément tiré sur les bâtiments pour
en en
battant l'as en retard retraite parce
que maintenant les
les groupes qui comptent qui se battent
encore de l'armée ukrainienne ils sont
concentrés dans trois grands bâtiments
industriels dans trois usines en fait en
donc en périphérie de mario pole mais je
me demande d'ailleurs quand quand mario
paul sera un jour reprise par les
troupes se craignaient que lettre citée
trouvera-t-on là bas parce que bouddha
est une toute petite île alors que
machenaud paul
qui a subi et continue de subir
donc
la coupure totale des communications et
ses trains et la ville continue à être
bombardé les civils continuent à tuer je
pense qu'on découvrira les horreurs
encore beaucoup plus grande mais
parallèlement je dis juste ça
le soutien de la population russe à
poutine s'accroît donc ces images
apparemment
je sais
je n'ai pas même d'explication
rationnelle à cela à part que la
propagande est très habile mais 83% des
russes plus le d'un pour cent en une
semaine approuve cette guerre est sur ma
carrière oui il ya un poids de
l'idéologie qui est très important qu'on
retrouve autant dans le phénomène
d'opinion la popularité de poutine a
augmenté très vite au début de la guerre
ici encore plus frappant elle croit
effectivement et puis le soldat de base
est aussi mû par cette idéologie lac est
un véritable lavage de cerveau donc si
vous arrivez à convaincre une troupe en
particulier des hommes très jeunes qui
ne sont jamais trop sortis de chez eux
des soldats de 18 ans qui sont
évidemment dont la condition est peu
enviable qui sont dans le civil ou qui
sont la rue militaire et que vous les
endoctriner au point de leur enseigner
lui qui se trouve en face est un nazi
que c'est un sous-homme et le c'est un
danger public il faut l'éliminer etc
vous avez un effet classique hélas des
guerres qui est l'effet d'idéologique le
fait de fanatisme qui produit sur ses
troupes des capacités meurtrière tout à
fait froid yable compte comparaison
n'est pas raison mais ça fait penser
aussi à d'autres massacres et l'as adema
saxons vieux dont les atrocités de la
guerre et des massacres de d'armé en
repli oradour sur glane à fait certaine
façon on va massacrer un village
vers 640 habitants avant de lâcher les
lieux comme un message adressé au maquis
et la population oui vous avez raison du
reste du pays ça fait pour moi ça me
fait ça fait écho à ce type de
populations civiles dans des lieux très
restreint des autres comparaisons à mon
avis et raison puisque fait une
comparaison avec la deuxième guerre
mondiale est précisément cette guerre
d'ukraine prend c'est là le tournant que
vous évoquez tout à l'heure thomas prend
des allures de
effroyable qui évoque la deuxième guerre
mondiale y compris dans l'élimination
comme ça deux groupes humains
qui sont hors de proportion avec avec
l'enjeu plein jeu initiale qui était
pas du tout d'arriver à exterminer une
partie de la population du un petit vide
une petite ville comme
coco bout de champ mais que mais comme
disait gaillard peut-être kamayou paul
l'on va découvrir des horreurs encore
pire alors je jouerai quand même moi je
me souviens de ce qui s'était passé en
décembre 89 j'étais jeune journaliste en
poste à paris le charnier de timisoara
peut-être que vous vous en souvenez
aussi on est au début de la révolution
roumaine quelques jours avant la chute
la mort de ceausescu et de nombreux
médias occidentaux on s'en souvient
mathieu ont été piégés voilà en face au
corps d'une vingtaine de personnes
attribuent leur décès la police
politique la securitate bon on a appris
plus tard que ces corps ils avaient été
exhumés de de la morgue et que c'était
une manipulation je rappelle ça pour
vous poser une question je ne suggère
combien de temps ça peut prendre pour
dire ce qui s'est passé à bout de chat
c'est le fait de l'armée russe est pas
une manipulation fait un peu obligé dans
un débat comme ça y est cette question
c'est ça prend du temps
le temps de la justice et la journée ça
arrive tout à l'heure les gens de la
justice n'est pas le même que et les
temps les crimes sont en temps réel on
peut pas juger enquêter alors que les
crimes sont en train d'être commis il
faut qu'il ya une juridiction impartiale
neutre qui enquêtent il ya plusieurs
étapes ya l'étape de désert qu'elle
enquête sur la réalité des faits est ce
que les faits ont été commis comment ils
ont été commis sur qui est ce qu'il
s'agissait de personnes protégées quelle
ce qui sont les victimes et ses terres
est ce qu'il ya des témoins skd insider
des d'effecteur des personnes qui
peuvent venir
expliquer ensuite et c'est là le plus
compliqué c'est ça qui prend du temps il
faut remonter la chaîne de commandement
il faut remonter le système de la chaîne
de commandement le système militaires
des armées régulières mais aussi des
paramilitaires mais aussi d'autres
groupes qui peuvent avoir eu un rôle
dans l'assurance habité il faut essayer
de trouver de la documentation qui
permettent aussi d'établir qu'il ya eu
une intentionnalité puisqu'on se sent
des crimes qui nécessite comme tous les
crimes une intention mais une intention
particulière pour les crimes de guerre
et des crimes contre l'humanité encore
le génocide à une attention toute
particulière
donc ça c'est difficile de prouver
l'intention lorsqu'il s'agit de regarder
au plus haut niveau la planification des
crimes donc ça peut prendre beaucoup de
temps par contre il ya aussi une
question stratégie pénale
lorsqu'il ya une vraie volonté d'aller
de l'avant lorsqu'il ya des ressources
ce qu'on voit là aujourd'hui la france a
donné de l'argent à apporter son soutien
en termes de ressources le royaume uni
aussi à la cour pénale internationale va
apporter du personnel gratis
tout 42 états ont apporté leur soutien
ont fait un renvoi devant la cour pénale
internationale pour demander qui est une
enquête sur l'a7 sur le créneau par la
cpi c'est du jamais vu historiquement il
n'ya rien soutient un plébiscite pour la
justice internationale contre la pour la
lutte contre l'impunité qui est vraiment
tout à fait étonnant vertueux on peut
s'interroger sur peut-être
le fait de savoir pourquoi un tel
soutien n'existe pas dans d'autres
situations aujourd'hui un triste
anniversaire de des attaques chimiques
sur iphone en syrie néanmoins c'est une
bonne chose que les l'ensemble des pays
de l'union européenne est renvoyé la
situation à la cbi donc on peut imaginer
que dans cette situation là lorsqu'il ya
un fort soutien ça puisse aller un petit
peu plus vite d'accord mais ensuite
l'émission d'un mandat d'arrêt là le
fait que les juges doivent revoir
l'ensemble des charges qui sont
apportées par le procureur
et ensuite il faut compter sur la
coopération des états là où réside la
difficulté c'est que le temps médiatique
c'est tellement raccourci à une telle
impatience à voir les régions c'est
pendant ce temps là il ya les thèses
complotistes qui continue de c'est un
défi qui est quasiment impossible à la
cool
les états ont voulu une cour pénale
attention à qui interviennent en temps
réel oui en 98
or la justice n'intervient jamais en
temps réel donc le procureur
effectivement il a à la fois cette ce
rôle d'épée de damoclès ans quand il a
ouvert décidé d'ouvrir une enquête sur
la base de ses saisines par des états il
a effectivement indiqué aux parties
prenantes la cour pénale internationale
est compétente attention elle est là
d'accord détente gagné ackermann est ce
que dans votre for intérieur vous dit
vladimir poutine sera jugé un jour où
est-ce que vous n'arrivez pas à y croire
c'est difficile d'y croire je suis
plutôt pessimiste je pense que la
justice internationale
y'a pas moyen qu'il soit livré à la
donc on va le juger en son absence mais
même dans son propre pays faut-il pour
qu'il puisse être jugé qu'il soit
d'abord renversé sa emprisonnés et c'est
pas gagné cela
donc
je pense que vous savez à la limite
c'est pas très important qu'il soit jugé
ou non ce qui est important c'est que ce
etc
exact ces actes soient jugés et puis
vous savez poutine il est autant c'est
pas poutine qui a donné l'ordre de tuer
les gens en boccia ou ailleurs je pense
que ce qui se passe c'est ça me
ressemble un peu ça ressemble un peu à
ce qui se passait à la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale quand les troupes
soviétiques ont commencé leur marche à
travers l'europe pour arriver à berlin
finalement et tout le monde le sait
maintenant il ya eu deux millions de
femmes allemandes violée il y avait
aussi la rapine absolument incroyable le
pillage de la population les fameuses
photos de soldats russes avec cinq
paires de montres etc on envoyait des
wagons et des wagons des échelons entier
de biens pillés ce qui se passe
actuellement en ukraine c'est pareil il
ya des des bazars en biélorussie où les
soldats russes vendent ce qu'ils ont
pillé et il ya une société bélarusse qui
organise le transfert des biens pillés
vers la russie donc ce qui est important
c'est que peut-être l'armée russe sache
je ne sais pas s'il va le savoir est ce
que c'est une question de communication
que chacun qui est impliqué dans ce
crime pourrait être trop tard puni et
peut-être
dernière chose
vous savez quand staline
il y avait beaucoup de généraux à la fin
de la seconde guerre mondiale qui ont
été très indigné de ce ce comportement
de l'armée par des viols collectifs par
par les meurtres tout totalement impuni
de civils par le pillage et donc on a
fait le rapport à staline et staline a
dit m'a écouté ils ont ils ont
fait faire un chemin très dur il faut
t'y piste se relâcher un peu c'est ce
n'était pas un ordre
c'était il n'y avait pas d'autres de
poursuivre en justice alors que
normalement tous ces faits sont punis en
temps de guerre même par une peine de
mort faut-il continuer de négocier la
dîmière poutine regardez ce qu'on dit le
premier ministre polonais mateusz
moravia çi monsieur le président il
s'adresse au président français monsieur
le président macron combien de fois avez
vous négocié avec poutine qui avez vous
obtenu on ne débat pas on ne négocie pas
criminel les criminels doivent être
combattus personne n'a négocié avec
hitler est ce que vous négociez avec
hitler et staline avec paul pote
christian makarian est ce qu'on a le
choix voyez ce que je veux dire c'est
comment faire stopper cette guerre ou
alors c'est on négocie pas et la seule
le seul moyen de stopper la guerre ce
sera deux une victoire militaire ce qui
est terrible avec cette guerre c'est
qu'elle efface complètement les lignes
et nos certitudes et y compris et
surtout démocratique on vient de parler
du problème de la justice de la lenteur
la justice il faut que la justice ait le
temps de sa sérénité bon ça convient pas
aux stades émotionnels on a besoin d'une
solution immédiate ça c'est un des
problèmes des démocraties postmoderne
qui sont très rapides et un problème
comme celui que soulève le prémice
polonais ça n'est un autre c faut-il
interrompre la diplomatie au nom de deux
erreurs commises mais là c'est qu'une
question d'opinion moi je ne peux que
vous donner la mienne je pense que ça ne
résoudra rien de couper tous les canaux
avec vladimir poutine ça n'est en aucun
cas je suis navré pour monsieur le
premier ministre polonais de nature à le
freiner en aucun cas de nature à
l'intimider donc c'est un autre sujet la
diplomatie ne traite pas de l'arrêt des
hostilités dans l'occurrence puisque les
deux belligérants ukrainiens et russes
doivent a vu arriver un point critique
ou non pas l'un l'emportent mais où
quelque part la négociation devient
enfin possible et malheureusement c'est
un point paroxystique dans la violence
atteinte je dirais même que dans les
écoles du kgb on apprend quelque chose
d'atroce nous sommes ici en occident on
pense gagnant gagnant par exemple madame
merkel ouvre ne prépare l'organisation
de nord stream 2 parce que les russes y
gagneront ils vendront plus facilement
leur gaz et nous on y gagnera pas ce
qu'on sera approvisionné en toute
sécurité s'appelle indigne gagnant
gagnant dans les écoles du cac et
meurent là qu'on apprend le deal perdant
perdant tu as perdu
de parent j'ai perdu donc tu vas perdre
et ça c'est terrifiant sévère que les
russes y penserait selon ce mode de
pensée alors ça je suis sûr pour avoir
pu un petit peu approché ce cercle a que
vanille mûre poutine pense de cette
manière là si je perds en ukraine alors
ils perdront et paieront très cher le
but de garder une liaison du plan
sanitaire c'est pas de convaincre
poutine répondant à une logique si on
est bon on dit plausible on laisse la
porte ouverte alors au cas où ça une
envie dans tout à fait là dieu ça c'est
le premier point est le deuxième point
c'est que quand même la guerre ne
pouvant pas durer dieu merci à
perpétuité il va falloir et c'est le
rôle d'un chef d'état non pas imaginer
des sanctions des punitions des phrases
définitives mais il faut trouver une
perspective de sortie et la libre assis
ça sert à ça il faut une perspective
sans perspective ya plus aucune aucune
espérance et dans un conflit il faut
engendré de l'espérance le rôle de la
diplomatie c'est d'entretenir cette
espérance alors vous avez parlé de du
gaz russe et nord de nord stream de ces
images de deux bouts de chats elles ont
aussi fait irruption dans notre campagne
présidentielle on va écouter les
réactions de deux candidats et ce a
relancé le débat autour de d'un embargo
sur le gaz russe vous propose deux
points de vue opposés celui de marine le
pen et de yannick jadot avec un moyen de
forcer vladimir poutine au cessez-le-feu
et à la fin de ces atrocités c'est
d'arrêter d'importer du gaz et du
pétrole russes tous les jours tous les
jours l'europe donne 800 millions de
dollars à poutine pour financer sa
guerre et donc poursuivre ces atrocités
il ya un moment l'indignation ça suffit
en fait on peut pas à la fois s'indigner
et donné 800 millions de dollars à coup
tin tous les jours donc il faut cet
embargo j'essaie je voulais d'être
toujours de défendre toujours l'intérêt
de la france et des français c'est la
raison pour laquelle je me suis opposé
d'ailleurs aux sanctions qui touchent le
gaz et le pétrole russe parce que je
savais très bien que la conséquence
serait une inflation terrible pour les
français une augmentation spectaculaire
des prix de l'énergie oria 9 millions de
pauvres dans notre pays
mathieu comment les candidats notamment
ceux comme marine le pen qui était pro
poutine avant la guerre ont-ils réagi
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux à ces
images de de boudhha utilisons tous
condamnés à une condamnation unanime
évidemment du massacre de boudhha après
est ce qu'on désigne les coupables ou
pas alors il y en a qui parlent les
autorités russes y en a qui parlent de
responsables à trouver
tout le monde à crémines pas vladimir
poutine et qui adore le fait aussi réagi
emmanuel macron ne le fait pas il parle
pas nommément de vladimir poutine marine
le pen non plus jean dunand lieu
d'argent non plus eric zemmour non plus
mais ils sont quand même dans une
posture un peu curieuse nos amis poutine
au fil et russophile parce que eux qui
déclarait avoir de l'admiration pour la
demi-heure poutine billets déclaré
vouloir dès la demi-heure poutine
français on est à six jours du du
premier tour jean luc mélenchon qui
déclarait que la russie n'interviendrait
ports d'ukraine qui ne croyaient pas à
la guerre et c'est
eric zemmour qui pensaient que c'était
la russie l'agressé est dans une forme
d'amnésie collective
alors que on en a débattu au moment du
24 février au début d'intervention ce
sujet là des responsabilités et des
prises de positions de chacun il semble
s'être évaporée regarder les scores dans
les sondages de marine le pen ou deux où
de jolies fleurs je l'entends parler
dans de marine le pen qui est la seule
de toutes les personnalités politiques
françaises à avoir a rendu visite
personnellement à vladimir poutine à la
veille du premier tour de 2017 et à 5
ans et avoir réussi c'est là qu'elle
montre son talent à le faire oublier
galia ackerman comment les on évoque les
sanctions et la possibilité qui est
effectivement de nouvelles sanctions
décidées par notamment l'union
européenne comment les premières
sanctions sont vécues par les russes
dans leur vie quotidienne quelles
conséquences sont déjà tangibles les
premières conséquences c'est quand même
une montée de prix et puis la pénurie
de certains produits par exemple
bizarrement du sucre et ceci n'est pas
du tellement aux sanctions mais à la
guerre même en ukraine parce que le
crâne est un grand producteur de sucre
et de l'huile de tournesol par exemple
il ya plus d'huile de tournesol pas
seulement en russie en plusieurs groupes
et aussi et donc il ya une pénurie de
sucre ensuite il ya les grandes
enseignes qui sont partis et certaines
enseignes très emblématiques comme ikea
me casse c'était quelque chose vraiment
le la russie se rapprocher de l'occident
et ils ont reçu la possibilité que qui
n'a jamais existé pendant toute la
période soviétique
d'équiper leurs maisons de meublés avec
des meubles pratiques pas très cher etc
et donc il ya un plein de disparition et
le mc donald's king qui est partie de
ses trains mais je crois que les vraies
conséquences
vont s'étaler sur plusieurs mois
parce que pour l'instant c'est plutôt
l'inconfort voyez les gens ne peuvent
plus
par exemple il ya plein de retraités qui
vivent à l'étranger et qui tirait de
l'argent parce que leur retraite arrivée
sur leur compte en russie maintenant ce
n'est plus possible il ya des dizaines
de milliers de personnes qui sont déjà
partis qui ont quitté le pays
précipitamment et on pense qu'il y aura
encore des dizaines de milliers de
personnes qui vont partir qu'ils partent
souvent dans ce qu'on appelle le proche
étranger
ils partent dans les pays baltes et
partent en géorgie ils partent en
arménie il part que même au kazakhstan
même le kazakhstan semble maintenant oui
un havre de de liberté de paix mais
rapport
sur c'est sur cette thématique ou
peut-être sur les sanctions éventuelles
parce qu'on est déjà les sanctions les
quatrième train de sanctions on prépare
le cinquième elles ont eu leur
efficacité mais pas nécessairement au
point d'influer sur les décisions
militaires ou sur des exactions ou sur
des crimes de guerre comme ce qui a été
commis abuja il faut d'urgence si
l'europe veut exister inventer un autre
type de diplomatie humanitaire pas
militaire mais un humanitaire de
projection un humanitaire d'intervention
et je trouve que l'europe est assez peu
créative en matière humanitaire et quads
et 100 dos casque bleu européen louis et
des sortes vous savez il ya des navires
hôpitaux il ya des moyens transportable
projetable ses proches du terrain pour
aider des populations qui peuvent peser
sur les conflits et là je m'en suis un
peu intimidé les belligérants merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat